hey everybody welcome to caroico in
garden this is a planet coaster projects
in which unlike all of the series which
have made so far I'll be working only on
a garden not on a roller coaster or a
theme park or anything even remotely
related to that it's going to be
exclusively a Japanese garden now the
reason for that is partly because I just
really love Japanese gardens and I've
been wanting to do this for such a long
time already also partly because I'm
actually in Japan now and I can actually
get some inspiration from around here
and go on a bit of field trip research
also partly because we finally have some
autumn foliage so I can get some autumn
colors of Japanese gardens into this and
finally I've just always been wanting to
try something other than a theme park
these I think is a creative game planet
coaster allows you to do a lot more than
just the one thing that it's more or
less built for so all that considered
let's get into the time-lapse and see
how this thing shapes up over time all
right now one of the first things that I
did is not work on the gun in itself but
open up an empty park map because I
wanted to make a bit of custom foliage
because for one there is not too much
foliage in the game anyway and I just
wanted to have a little bit more variety
than what we have so far
even though I started this not too long
before the adventure update was
announced and unfortunately although
also fortunately it looks like we'll be
getting bamboo I'm not entirely sure but
it looks that way so at some of the
foliage that I was really missing at
this point unfortunately I couldn't get
into the gun in itself but there's a lot
of other stuff that I really wanted to
get in here and the most prominent
example I would say would be the Akari
Komi which is not specifically any type
of tree it can be a lot of types of
bushes or trees but it's this this sort
of round shaped foliage that you see in
a lot of Japanese gardens these bushes
and trees that have these big balls of
leaves that are
they're sort of shaped like European
topiaries I would say or at least they
have the same sort of idea but instead
of the European ones where they're very
geometrical and they have like shapes of
perfect circles or squares things like
that these are very natural they sort of
have much more free-flowing patterns to
their clusters and they have a very
distinct look it's sort of hard to
describe it but you'll probably be able
to tell what I'm sort of going for when
you see what's happening on the screen
right now or when you see some Japanese
gardens with these bushes that sort of
flow everywhere in these very wavy
patterns so that's the original idea
that I started these trees off with but
sort of in hindsight what I realized is
that they're actually a lot more like
Japanese pine trees which to be honest
the Akari Komi and the Japanese pine
trees are the two types of foliage that
I was really missing in the game to make
a Japanese garden so I'll be getting to
both of these and these are really
they're just the two crucial things to
give it that Japanese look but what
makes these more look like Japanese
pines is that their clusters are much
smaller they have way more and just over
there all mm-hmm just overall the
texture of the bush
I think matches a Japanese pine much
more than it matches sort of around
topiary bush that said I'm still not
entirely sure how much I like the look
they don't exactly look like the pine
trees I just think it's practically
impossible to create anything exactly
like that so I've just decided to use
these as a substitute for them in the
end I miss named the blueprints at the
time because I still thought I would use
these as bushes when I made them but
they're gonna be the Japanese pine trees
and I'll get to the bushes at some later
stage in any case the whole idea behind
this bit of custom foliage was just to
have a few sort of variations on this
tree that's why I made a few different
ones just so you can actually have that
slight natural variation and just
scatter these throughout the garden in
the sort of pattern that will hopefully
make it look like a convincing Japanese
garden
now next I wanted to get to the Akari
call me themselves which is a little bit
easier I think than the other trees
since most of these are going to just be
these round bushes and the trick is not
so much making the bushes themselves but
really when I get into the garden
placing these bushes in the right ways
and placing them in a sort of natural
free-flowing pattern because there's a
lot that I can note about when it comes
to Japanese gardens but overall the way
that I would you know very quickly try
to describe them is that they're sort of
the opposite of Western Gardens in the
sense that Western Gardens are very
unnatural usually they just involve
these very big compositions of all kinds
of flowers and trees and they they do
show of you know if you will those sort
of beauty of nature but they're not
really placed in a very natural sense
very often especially if you look at
stuff like French gardens where you've
got all of these geometric patterns
going on it's very man-made whereas on
the other and Japanese gardens are very
natural not in a sense that they are
exactly like in nature they're very much
more of a miniature version and they're
more like emulating nature than they're
recreating it but they try to go for a
more natural flow and so you won't have
any of these very artificial looking
elements and arrangements you won't have
any very geometric shapes and any of the
trees and bushes everything will be more
natural basically so that's the overall
idea it's kind of like Japan is trying
to live with nature where Western
Gardens are beating it into submission
sort of even though that sounds very
negative I don't want to slam Western
Gardens in any way but that's the thing
that I do like about Japanese gardens is
that they're the sort of nature I don't
know if anybody has seen this video yet
I definitely recommend watching it it's
a planet bro coaster pro basics video
about nature which explains the idea of
arranging trees and bushes in such a way
that it looks natural in a theme park
but it's actually very men
and I think a very similar concepts sort
of applies through Japanese garnets as
well they try to look very natural and
they emulate natural landscapes but in
the end there are some they're also
man-made so finally I wanted to create
this really big pine tree and that's I
believe the last thing that I did in
terms of foliage yep here we go here it
goes for the actual shaping of the lake
itself I think I missed a little bit of
the bushes that I was making but it's
not too special all of these bushes are
just some of these typical round ball
shaped bushes that you'll typically find
in Japanese gardens and now I wanted to
head into shaping the lake of the garden
itself oh and this is this is where
where the nerd stuff is gonna get off
the charts so basically the idea that
I'm taking for this garden because there
are different types of Japanese gone and
so the idea that I'm taking for this
garden is that I wanted to create a
garden that looks like a strolling
garden from the Edo period in Japan
which were usually gardens that were
meant to be walked through to sort of
see all the views that you had they also
had all kinds of different uses that
I'll get into in a bit but they were a
type of garden that you don't just see
from one perspective you're supposed to
walk through them and you're supposed to
do activities in them and see them from
different angles and usually there is
also a lake in the middle of these and
you're sort of making your way around
the lake with all of these typical
Japanese picturesque places like little
bridges over some small streams hey you
know stuff like that it's pretty
romantic it's pretty cool and mostly I
was inspired by the daimyo gardens in
Tokyo and without going too much into
history here basically the way things
used to be is that Japan used to be all
of these different little places with
their own rulers but there was one ruler
in Tokyo which was the Shogun which was
like the military ruler now that the
rule where all of the rulers from all
the rest of Tokyo all of their little
places all these feudal lords they had
to have a home in Tokyo where they live
every now and then which was basically
the way
for the main ruler of
and to keep them all hostage and make
sure that everybody listens to him and
the cool sort of side effect that this
has is that basically Tokyo in those
days when it was called Edo and why
their period is called the Edo period
Tokyo is was basically for all of these
estates for these daimyo which is the
feudal lords of all these areas in Japan
and as a result it was full of all of
these sick houses and really cool
estates with gardens and some of these
are still left in Tokyo and nowadays the
few remaining daimyo conan's are some of
their like main parks in the city and
some of the most beautiful gardens there
are also a few newer ones but this is
really the inspiration that I'm getting
here and the cool bit is that I've
actually been able to visit all of these
and actually take a lot of pictures and
film a lot of stuff and get some
references from this I might also turn
this into the video let me know if you
think that's interesting enough because
I'd love to get into it a little bit
more but yeah I've been able to visit
most of these I've been to the Coogee
and I've been to korakuen garden I've
been to hamari Q&Q schibetta q gone and
as well as kya Sumi garden and of course
Shinjuku Gyoen which Shinjuku Gyoen I
guess is a really famous one it's
featured in quite a bit of anime
probably most famously the garden of
words by Makoto Shinkai because who else
pretty cool movie too but that's a
really famous one that you'll see a lot
of pictures of I actually picture all of
these in the screen so you've got you
get a bit of an idea but yeah this is
basically where I took my inspiration
from because all of these gardens have a
few things in common they all have this
big lake in the middle these Akari call
me everywhere and the overall sort of
style that I'll be going through in this
build now yeah I don't want to go too
much into those gun and specifically
that's definitely something that I'd
love to get into if I you know actually
do a separate video about that but there
are a few elements which you can sort of
lift from these things which I thought
were very interesting
and at the very least it gives you a
whole other feel for these places you
can look at pictures on the internet of
these kinds of places but I always find
it's really hard it's actually judge
what they look like from pictures a lot
of them are really this is gonna sound
so way over the top but you'll never be
able to like find every angle from every
part of that garden and that's more or
less the thing of these gardens is there
a sort of moving gallery of paintings I
think there's a lot of economic
literature about the similarities
between landscape paintings and gardens
in East Asia and the idea behind these
gardens that I like so much about them
is that as you sort of walking through
them there's always a bit of a fist
there's always a bit of a Vista and
there's always like some part where you
can look at and it looks kind of like a
painting you've also and you've always
got this sort of landscape and it
changes from every angle and it changes
from every place that you'll be standing
and that's something that you can't
really emulate so well via any images or
even some Google Streetview there is
some pretty cool Google Streetview in
that you can do in these gardens in
Tokyo and if you're into that kind of
stuff I definitely recommend it but it's
still kind of restricted you can never
go onto all of the paths and you can
never quite get the same idea what I
actually found very funny is that when
going to these gardens and I went mostly
around the seasons that the autumn
leaves were actually red most of the
time there were like over half of the
Japanese people were all just taking
pictures with most of the people also
having pretty good cameras and it was
really interesting it's like everybody
was just going there exclusively to take
pictures but yeah that's all for those
real life gone in size should definitely
catch up a little bit on what's
happening in planet coaster I've
basically secured the parameter god
isn't that like freaking yeah that's the
wrong lingo it's a hit you to use here
I've basically put this big wall around
the cone and because I wanted to fit it
in and especially if you look at Gardens
like cushy Valley Q or the cookie end in
Ikebukuro you'll find that they're very
much in this sort of square parameter
which has been squared off by the growth
of Tokyo around it and I wanted to do
something similar with this garden so I
put that wall right there to keep it
quite small and this is really small
this would actually be I think the
smallest gone in in Tokyo if it were
actually to exist so as much as I'm
trying to make this large it is really
really small I haven't never i haven't
measured it exactly but I think it's not
actually I have I think if I remember
correctly it's 55 tiles by about 60
tiles which would be a little around 1/4
kilometer lengthy in terms of length and
width as well so I'm not entirely how
sure how much like square kilometers
that is but that's very small you can
walk through the whole thing in not even
that many minutes most likely in about
10 minutes to 15 minutes you should have
been able to see the whole thing
so yeah that's definitely one of the
ideas from these Japanese gardens is
that by creating this sort of routes
along which you can scroll to stroll
through the gardens it is always a bit
of a loop that you can complete and then
you've seen the whole thing and you've
seen all of the vistas from all the
different angles and along the way as
you'll be seeing over here you've got
some hills a lot of interaction with the
water where the water sort of represents
the sea as a big lake in the middle of
the park and they've got some branches
running off from that a little bit more
like rivers if you will and then the
hills sort of represents the mountains
everything sort of is a miniature
version of real nature in this way and
there's even a little bit of force
perspective sometimes and how it works
because these things are definitely
meant to look a lot bigger than they
actually are because in reality they
really are quite small so yeah that's
generally the idea behind what I'm doing
here and yeah that's quite interesting
because you can you can see that a lot
of the elements are in fact very much
like miniature nature so I'm also making
a very small Beach over there on the
other side of the mountain the mountain
itself by the way which I originally
model
after Mount Fuji a little bit that might
sound kind of stupid but you actually
find that a lot of the lucky highest
hills in Japanese gardens are a
reference to Mount Fuji and have some
sort of reference also in their name
it's a Mount Fuji so it's something that
I wanted to try in this garden as well
I'll just be taking a lot either
directly or indirectly from real
Japanese gardens here there's also all
kinds of symbolism I haven't gone into
the symbolism completely I mean I have a
little bit but I always keep forgetting
certain stuff but in case there is some
sand and gravel usually represent rivers
or flowing water so especially if you've
got some of those rock gardens and
you'll have some streams of sand and
stuff like that or even sand waterfalls
or gravel waterfalls these are the sort
of miniature elements that actually
represent rivers and waterfalls whereas
the rocks that you'll find in every
Japanese garden and the rockwork is
truly on point is is usually
representing the mountains in the
country and I think even in a sort of
similar way all of those small shrubs
that they carefully keep in all of these
shapes they they do sort of have the
same rolling feeling as seeing large
stretches of mountains going over trees
so yeah they're not exactly a miniature
because they're not literally creating
miniature mountains or mini into rivers
or tiny trees like bonsai but it gives
off the same sort of feelings it's it's
an emulation so yeah that's pretty
interesting I think and also who has
interesting details I took some
inspiration for some of the weirdest
things in this garden so I'm copying
some fence designs if you will I'm I
wouldn't call them designs that that
makes them sound way too good I just
took some ideas from fences from the
garnets as well so I was
enthusiastically taking pictures of
wooden posts and ropes in the garden and
it must have looks really weird but
probably not half as weird as all the
Japanese people taking pictures of the
maple trees so I guess that's what
people do in Japan
gardens anyway so um I did take that and
used it to actually make the offensives
over here so yeah it might be a boring
touch but a lot of these places have the
simple wooden posts with ropes to
demarcate the paths or some stretch
bamboo to just make these tiny little
arches to keep you on the paths so
that's something that I lifted from that
also I wanted to make the ground look
pretty ugly and have largely dead grass
and mud since that is to be honest
usually this sort of autumn feel and
look of the ground I have seen some
parks where the grass actually
surprisingly green still near the end of
the autumn season but some of them also
have very dead grass quite early on in
the season and it's just something that
happens in autumn no grass doesn't grow
so that's something that I also wanted
to put in here just to create a bit more
of the autumn look it's one of the few
things which I think makes doing autumn
and winter parks a little bit more
difficult because all the foliage is
usually actually a lot less impressive
plus a lot of this depends on how good
the foliage looks and obviously the Four
Asian planet coaster even though it's
quite good it doesn't look like those
beautiful autumn pictures of Japan and
amazing forests in the mountains so it
takes quite a bit of work I guess to
actually make these look like a nice
garden because you know all of the the
beauty from a gun and pretty much comes
from the foliage and a lot of it comes
down to me I don't wanna blame the game
for making it difficult to make this
sort of stuff but you can't really look
you can't really rely on amount of
detail or on building composition in
this sort of case it really just comes
down to how you place the the foliage oh
also something that I should probably
still mention I think I mentioned in the
beginning of the video I would go into
the users of these Gardens a little bit
more it's not even that interesting
anyway but these gardens were apparently
used for quite a bit of stuff
be it entertainment or serious stuff
like Japanese people like to go on in
these things and write poems or whatever
it is that they would writes in terms of
their literature arts or even use them
to go hunting or have any kinds of
events eat together with people or
whatever there's a sort of place where
you just want to be and that's actually
quite important because sort of in
Japanese spirituality especially if you
look at their Shinto religion which is
hot stuff and it only exists in Japan or
pretty much how many people seriously
follow it in Japan it's like nature is
the most important sort of thing in life
and God that's a horrible way to
describe it in any case being parts of
nature being in nature is the the very
point of these gardens in these this
kind of spirits so being in a garden is
supposed to sort of lift your spirits
and make you less stressed and overall
just be a positive part of life and make
you feel good when you're not feeling
good about yourself or something like
that it's it's pretty important anyway
you know this was back in the days when
Japan hadn't invented Nintendo and you
know they didn't have any Pokemon yet or
anything so surely they had to have some
other things to keep themselves happy so
yeah these gardens were actually quite
an important part of life and they still
are there's still some of the very few
spaces where you can actually find a big
green space in Tokyo because Tokyo is
ridiculously dense in fact something
I've been meaning to talk about it is
one of the main aspects of these gardens
that unfortunately I probably won't be
able to feature so much in this one is
the idea of Shiki which is borrowed
scenery and it means the way in which
it's gonna sort of uses the scenery
around it to make the gone in itself
better so there's this really famous
modern Japanese garden which uses a
cliff that's just outside the garden to
sort of be part of the Vista inside the
garden itself and this is really cool a
way to make the gun and seem a little
bit larger than it really is but
unfortunately since I'm just building
this in an empty sandbox there isn't
really anything outside
I'll be able to use as such a thing but
the the real ones in Tokyo have this
interesting dynamic where you'll have
the garden in the in the foreground and
in the background these ridiculous
skyscrapers everywhere and it's just
really cool in terms of how the contrast
works obviously it's different from you
know the past years where the background
might have been some cool here or a
temple or the sea in the case of how
many Kew Gardens but still it's quite
cool in any case that's just the minutes
for this video so I want to thank you
guys so much for watching this and
somehow being able to probably possibly
keep going through all of my new events
here and hopefully I'll see you guys in
the next episode in which I'll be
working on some of the bridges and some
more hill stuff and definitely get in a
lot more foliage into the garden so yeah
thanks for watching and bye bye
[Music]
[Music]